today's video is brought to you by
athletic greens supplement your health
and nutrition with their daily blend of
vitamins and minerals aesthetic greens
is a comprehensive all-in-one greens
powder engineered to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet and
support your body's nutritional needs
across four pillars of health gut health
immune support energy and recovery it's
packed with 75 vitamins and minerals and
whole food-sourced ingredients combining
the perfect amount of micronutrients
absorption and taste jump start your
daily routine be hard-pressed to find a
more comprehensive powder and supplement
on today's market and i have to put this
in my other hand because it's cold
because it was in the fridge
look you guys know i'm not a fitness
youtuber you're probably not coming to
my channels for squatting tips but i
don't even
what is a squat but i do like to eat
right and take care of myself and
athletic greens is the comprehensive
supplement that you know is going to
take care of any holes that you have in
your diet just one scoop into your water
bottle they actually provide all this
stuff this obviously tin comes from them
and then there is uh you can still see
it's wet from me washing it out this
morning and uh you put one scoop of this
stuff in the bottle you shake it up and
you drink it it looks very gr there's a
what what the weird thing in there is
the silica stuff to keep it dry you
scoop a scoop into the bottle you shake
it up and you're drinking it's easy and
it tastes good which honestly not
something i expected plus it's also
gluten-free dairy-free paleo-vegan keto
low-allergen and low calorie there's
less than one gram of sugar per serving
one of the things that i like about it
is generally i drink too much coffee
this has replaced one of my morning
coffees which is uh
healthier athletic greens is the perfect
dietary supplement support regimen so if
this sounds like something you've been
looking for then you can grab your own
immunity bundle that's one year vitamin
d plus five individual travel packs for
free with your first purchase actually
have a bunch of travel packs as well
just go to athleticgreens.com forward
slash biographics again a year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs at
athletic greens dot com forward slash
biographics link in the description
below i gotta put this back in the
fridge
[Music]
i had to put it back in the fridge but
these are the travel packs by the way
super convenient and useful you don't
even really need to take the shaker just
take it and shake it up on the go
it was the great plague of the 19th
century in the midst of the monsoon
season of 1817 an infectious new strain
of vibrio cholerae emerged from the
wetlands of the ganges river delta first
fire contaminated rice and then via
dirty water it swept across the indian
subcontinent killing thousands upon
thousands those who fell ill died in
days or even hours their faces sunken
and blew with dehydration by the time
the pandemic burned itself out it
reached as far as japan in the east and
turkey in the west sadly this wouldn't
be the end over the coming decades six
more cholera pandemics would unfold each
reaching further and devastating new
populations by the end of the 19th
century the disease had killed tens of
millions and reached every continent
except for antarctica it also changed
the course of human history the
pandemics hit at a time where
understanding of science and medicine
was on the cusp of transformation even
as it ravaged cities cholera would bring
about light speed advances in healthcare
and sanitation advances that still
affect our lives to this very day
for almost everyone who contracts it
cholera is a remarkably benign illness
only around 20 percent of those infected
ever experience any symptoms of that 20
percent about 9 in 10 have a mild case
that clears up with no medical
intervention but for the 1 in 10 who do
develop serious problems benign is
probably the last word you'd use to
describe them the cause of this illness
is vibrio cholerae a bacterium that
loves chilling in warm shallow salt
water that means that it can be present
in shellfish caught in places like the
gulf of mexico but while possible collar
infections from seafood are relatively
rare of all the hundreds of strains of
vibrio cholerae only two are known to be
capable of causing outbreaks that means
most people who catch cholera won't do
so in a beachside restaurant or even
while gleefully swimming around in
bacteria-laden waters now most people
who get the disease get it thanks to
good old-fashioned human grossness they
touch or eat something contaminated with
someone else's pope you see the outbreak
causing strains release a toxin that
sends the cells lining your intestines
into overdrive making them release
massive amounts of fluid that excess
fluid results in horrendous diarrhea all
of which is loaded with millions more
vibrio cholerae ready to infect someone
else
in places and time periods with poor
sanitation that infectious fecal matter
can then contaminate the water supply
leading to more and more people getting
sick until you have an epidemic on your
hands and once a cholera epidemic has
taken hold it can be difficult as hell
to shake off despite both causes and
treatments being widely known today
cholera still infects up to 4 million
people annually around 143 000 of whom
will die so let's say you're unlucky
enough to be among those 4 million what
might you expect to happen if you
develop serious symptoms the answer is
you're probably going to have the worst
day of your life being sick with cholera
involves a whole lot of fluids coming
out of a whole lot of orifices in
quantities that we can only describe as
disgusting seriously patients lose so
much fluid so quickly that severe
dehydration can set in after only a
couple of hours famously this can lead
to sunken eyes and cold blue skin a
feature that once saw cholera named the
blue death once you reach that stage
things are pretty much over septic shock
and death can occur within hours of your
first symptoms untreated the mortality
rate is as high as 50 percent the good
news though is that treatment is
remarkably easy to come by armed with
nothing more than oral rehydration
solution doctors can save the lives of
99 of all cholera patients the upshot if
you catch cholera in orbit the poorest
countries today you're almost guaranteed
to survive but that's today with our
modern insights into disease
transmission and treatment when cholera
first emerged we knew none of this like
a blind man as an orgy humanity was
groping in the dark so now we've
established what cholera is it's time
for us to head back across the decades
all the way to the second decade of the
19th century and the birth of a new
pandemic
[Music]
if you want a wild example of the
butterfly effect look no further than
the story of mount tambora in april 1815
the indonesian volcano blew its top in
the biggest eruption of the past 2000
years so much ejecta was spewed out that
it altered the climate in europe some 9
000 kilometers away temperatures dropped
so sharply that the following year
became known as the year without summer
but while tambora's eruption would have
all sorts of far-reaching consequences
it was in the ganges river delta that it
had perhaps the greatest impact for two
years after the eruption the monsoon
pounded the river's wetlands with an
intensity unlike anything ever seen so
much rain fell that the entire region
became a vast swamp sadly for everyone
it was about to become apparent that
extreme rainfall plus endless swamp was
the perfect formula for creating a new
strain of vibrio cholerae at the moment
tambora went up cholera had been around
for centuries as early as the 5th
century bc a cholera-like illness was
recorded in an ancient indian medical
text known as the shushrata samhita
millennia later the portuguese historian
gaspar korea had detailed a 1543
outbreak around the bay of bengal but
while cholera was ancient it had never
made its way out of the disease bush
leaks it was sort of like coronaviruses
up until 2019 known about but
largely ignored but just like
coronaviruses in 2019 cholera was about
to get its big break at some point amid
the monsoon rains of summer 1817 a fluke
evolution created a new strain of vibrio
cholerae out in the drowned wetlands of
the ganges this strain multiplied
silently contaminating rice crops rice
that was then sent to the city of jasore
in modern-day bangladesh that august the
british doctor robert titler was
urgently called to the town bazaar
pulling back a curtain on a hut he found
an emaciated man who couldn't stop
vomiting within days of titler's ominous
meeting scores were dead in jason by
then cases had already appeared in
calcutta it was the beginning of the
first cholera pandemic the arrival of a
disease that would soon transform the
world but first it was going to kill a
metric heck ton of people all through
the following months funeral pars burned
around the clock a faint grisly glow
that slowly inexorably spread across
india because no one had ever seen
cholera like this before no one knew how
to treat it no one had any natural
immunity the result was an epidemic that
felled locals and colonial overlords
alike around the bay of bengal the
entire british army was effectively
wiped out but it also infected a much
more dangerous class of people
traders as cholera ravaged india trade
routes allowed it to spread further
sweeping along a wave of infections
first it reached what we call today ma
ma and sri lanka by 1820 it had gone
even further infecting both thailand and
indonesia on the island of java a
hundred thousand people are thought to
have been killed by the disease but it
didn't only afflict east asia one day in
1821 an ill-fated boat docked in oman on
board an unknown british soldier was
already feeling the onset of cholera
symptoms as soon as he disembarked the
disease began its assault on the middle
east that same year it spread into
turkey and syria in the town of basra
now part of iraq 18 000 people died in
just three weeks yet for all its power
the first pandemic would never quite
reach europe in 1824 following a severe
winter cholera suddenly burnt itself out
although it would continue causing havoc
in india it faded pretty much everywhere
else but if humanity was hoping that was
it they had another thing coming rather
than the end this was just a quick
timeout a pause so cholera could catch
its breath when it came back it would
have two new continents in its sight
europe
and north america
[Music]
in 1831 the russian capital of saint
petersburg found itself gripped by twin
pandemics the first and most dangerous
was cholera after fading in the early
1820s the disease had come roaring back
it rolled across imperial russia like a
tsunami at its height 600 were dying a
day in saint petersburg alone but the
other pandemic was in some ways just as
worrying as cholera victims piled high
rumors were swirling across the city
rumors that the cholera had been
released on purpose that it was a
government weapon designed to eliminate
russia's urban poor with travel
checkpoints and quarantines cutting
people off from work the disinformation
pandemic soon spread like wildfire
culminating in an armed mob attacking a
cholera hospital and murdering several
doctors it was one of the first great
cholera riots in europe over the coming
months they'd break out everywhere from
france to hungary to great britain but
they would all have one thing in common
they'd be fueled by disinformation
[Music]
in england the disinformation pandemic
was largely thanks to the media london
newspapers in 1832 were full of pundits
telling their readers that the
government had fabricated the cholera
crisis to distract from their failings
anonymous letters from alleged doctors
claimed that they'd been offered 20
guineas to falsely diagnose patients
with cholera others declared it a
foreign epidemic denouncing the asiatic
cholera affecting britain's shores up in
liverpool the rumors were even darker
there were reports that cholera was a
pretext for taking people into hospitals
to kill them so students could use the
bodies to practice medicine on with
memories of the birken hair murders or
fresher people's minds this seemed
horribly plausible so much so that in
may 1832 a thousand strong mob attacked
toxteth park hospital across britain as
a whole more than 70 cholera riots would
be reported that year egged on by an
uninformed media bad as the riots in
britain were though they were on a whole
other level in paris of all the western
european capitals the city of lights may
have suffered the worst from cholera in
march of 1832 a surge of patients
suddenly began washing into the hotel
dew hospital over the coming months some
20 000 would die killed by the awful
sanitation in a city where human waste
was dumped straight into open channels
in the middle of the street amid the
stench of death terrifying tales sprang
up like that of a society ball where one
man dressed as a harlequin removed his
mask after complaining of chills only
for the crowd to see that his face had
turned blue he died so quickly that he
was buried still wearing his costume but
while the rich did indeed get infected
with cholera it was mostly the poor who
died in fact the death toll was so
wildly different that rumors sprang up
that the government was poisoning
commoners alarmed by these rumors the
newly installed king louis philippe the
first demanded that his chief of police
give a speech to calm the people the
result was a tone deaf announcement
where the chief basically told the media
look i'm not poisoning the poor but
maybe someone is yeah should probably
print that that sounds about right eggs
on by such announcements paris was soon
seething with paranoia all it would take
would be one government misstep and
things would ignite that misstep finally
came on june the first that day the
beloved war hero general lamarck died of
cholera just weeks before louis philippe
had granted a state funeral for the
incredibly not beloved prime minister
casimir pierre perrier after he'd also
died of cholera so paris's poor demanded
one for lamarck do but because lamarck's
whole thing had been telling people how
crappy the new king was louis philippe
refused with that one shake of the royal
head the king let all of that pent out
anger come rushing out on june 5th the
protest at mark's funeral turned into
armed insurrection barriers went up in
the streets the poor and downtrodden
armed themselves they were determined to
overthrow their hated king but louis
philippe was going nowhere that june day
the july monarchy crushed the attempted
revolution
over a hundred were killed and scores
arrested in the following crackdown
among those who witnessed the uprising
was 30 year old victor hugo decades
later he would use it as the backdrop
for his most famous novel of all the
miserable
while the poor of paris were fighting
and dies a future generations might hear
russell crowe butcher show tunes
vibrio colorado was heading west to
check out the new world that same year
1832 the americans recorded their first
infections as the disease laid waste to
quebec from there the pandemic followed
the river down into the united states
before engulfing the eastern seaboard
famously this included the biggest
american city of them all new york at
the time nyc was not that different from
paris or london in that its poor
districts tended to be disgusting slums
filled with filth wild animals and
discarded fecal matter but since this is
america the spread of cholera also came
with a distinct ethnic dimension the
hardest hit part of nyc was a place
called five points a gigantic slum where
the city basically dumped all of its
irish immigrants and african americans
thanks to stuff like no irish need apply
signs plus good old-fashioned racial
discrimination those in five points were
not just outcasts but painfully poor so
when they all started dying of cholera
it allowed the great and good of new
york to paint it as something they
brought on themselves those sickened
must be cured or die off thundered john
pintard in one letter and being chiefly
of the very scum of the city that
quicker their dispatch the sooner the
malady will cease but hey at least
pintard stayed in the city to witness
the cholera most of nyc's rich simply
fled the reason greenwich village
suddenly expanded in 1832 was because a
whole lot of wealthy folk decided to
abandon the city to its fate and what a
gruesome fate that was in 1832 the
population of new york was 250 000 of
them 3500
would die of cholera that doesn't sound
like much just know this scaled for
nyc's population today that would be
like over a hundred thousand people
dying by comparison to date the covert
pandemic has killed 33 500 new yorkers
yet nyc wasn't even the hardest at
american city down in louisiana new
orleans saw 5 000 succumb to the cholera
nearly 10 percent of the population come
1833 cholera had spread into mexico and
cuba over the coming decades it would
continue to ravage the globe not as a
constant thing constantly killing people
but as a disease that popped up here and
there hitting places with nasty
outbreaks before fading back into the
background famously this included
another nyc outbreak in 1849 this time
one that killed over five thousand bad
as this was though it had nothing on
what came next today it's generally
accepted that the second cholera
pandemic had ended by 1851 but just as
the first pandemic had been followed by
the second the second would soon be
followed by the third and that third
cholera pandemic was the worst of the
lot erupting in 1852 the third pandemic
was the first one to seriously affect
africa killing people from uganda to
ethiopia it also returned to batter the
u.s and europe in 1854 23 000 people
would die in great britain yet the third
pandemic was much more than just a
public health catastrophe it was also
the moment that humanity at last began
fighting back
the thing to remember about 19th century
dudes is that they weren't idiots when
cholera first reared its ugly head they
didn't start whipping themselves on the
back and shouting alas lord why hast
thou forsaken us
but instead began working to figure out
what was causing this new disease as
early as 1842 the english lawyer edwin
chadwick had definitively proven a link
between poor sanitary conditions and not
just cholera but other diseases as well
unfortunately early attempts at
improving sanitation had disastrous side
effects chadwick for example was a
leading proponent of miasma theory the
then fashionable idea that diseases were
caused by toxic gases found in the
stench of feces and rotting matter
tasked with performing london sanitation
he worked overtime to clear the slums of
human waste sadly miasma theory held
that he only needed to get it far enough
away from people that they couldn't
smell it so chadwick designed drainage
that took raw sewage straight into the
river thames then london's main source
of drinking water the result was an
explosion of disease it's estimated that
chadwick's well-meaning reforms led to
cholera killing another 14 000 people
luckily the reform efforts wouldn't end
here even as chadwick was blissfully
paving the road to hell with his good
intentions a london doctor was working
to give humanity a new weapon against
the disease depending on your age and
your geographic location the name jon
snow likely either conjures images of
game of thrones or a dapper whitehead
man reading the news in a soothing
british accent really though we should
probably all be thinking of the 19th
century physician born on march the 15th
1813.
born on march 15 1813 jon snow is today
known as the father of epidemiology as
early as 1849 when london was reeling
from an outbreak he published a paper
showing that cholera was transmitted not
by bad air but by contaminated water
sadly the edwin chadwicks of the world
completely ignored snow's breakthrough
but the doctor would soon get a second
chance to prove his theory in september
1854 king cholera once again held court
in london around broad street in soho
people were falling in record numbers
616 people would die in that one
district alone curious why this
neighborhood was being so badly hit snow
plotted all the soho deaths on a map it
showed a district clustering around a
single water pump on broad street when
he examined the pump's water snow
observed what he called white flocculant
particles or what we'd now call vibrio
cholerae snow eventually managed to
convince the authorities to shut down
the pump while the outbreak was nearly
over by then it still proved his theory
of waterborne transmission incredibly
though the medical establishment still
refused to believe him it wasn't until
1866 that snow was proved right and then
it was only by a fluke in 1858 the
practice of dumping sewage into the
thames had created such an awful smell
in central london the parliament had to
be closed known as the great stink it
spurred lawmakers to commission the
first modern sewer system one that would
dump waste far from inhabited places by
the time cholera returned in 1866 only
east london wasn't connected to the new
sewers and surprise surprise that's
where all the deaths were it was final
proof that cholera was a waterborne
illness one that could be treated with
good sanitation and there were other
advances happening too down in italy
filippo paccini had become the first to
properly identify the bacteria that
caused cholera although it would also be
initially ignored paccini would later be
vindicated when robert repeated his
finding come the 1880s then the tide was
starting to turn against cholera
sanitation reforms had led to cities
like london and new york not just
becoming less diseased but also being
basically nicer places to live in
napoleon iii's paris baron houseman was
given carte blanche to recreate the city
in a way that encouraged sanitation and
light the result was the grand
boulevards and yellow limestone
architecture that we all associate with
paris today but while great battles were
being won in richer nations the war was
still far from over cholera may have
been weakened but it was going to
continue causing chaos for decades to
come
[Music]
the latter half of the 19th century saw
two more cholera pandemics neither as
brutal as the third one but each still
accompanied by a staggering body count
in 1884 for example 5 000 were killed in
the city of naples alone just a decade
earlier an outbreak in hungary resulted
in some 190 000 deaths while up to a
quarter of a million would die in russia
over the course of a single winter in
1883 at the same time the disease was
reaching the last parts of the globe
still left untouched in the 1890s the
bacteria finally spread throughout the
whole of south america by the time of
the sixth pandemic though it was already
evident how things were changing
beginning in 1899 the sixth cholera
pandemic dinged the world almost as
badly as the third half a million would
die in russia during the pandemic's 24
year run in the middle east mecca would
be repeatedly hit with tens of thousands
of pilgrims dying on both the 1902 and
1907 hajj yet there was one set of
countries that the sixth pandemic barely
touched in northern western europe and
in america and canada sanitation and
public health had now improved so
drastically the cholera passed by almost
unnoticed ever since it first emerged
cholera had been a global scourge one
that carried off more poor people sure
but that still touched the lives of the
rich the 11th president james k polk for
example is thought to have died from the
disease come the sixth pandemic though
it was clear that this was no longer
true from here on out cholera would be a
burden felt only by the poorer nations
in the decades since the lopsided effect
of cholera has only grown more
pronounced when the seventh pandemic
began in 1961 the only one to date not
to have originated in india it went
almost unnoticed in richer nations while
causing havoc in africa and latin
america fast forward to the 21st century
and it's now a disease of only the very
poorest the three great outbreaks since
2000 have all been centered on some of
the planet's most neglected nations
zimbabwe in 2008 haiti in 2010 and the
ongoing outbreak in yemen the saddest
part is that even these outbreaks should
never have happened as we said back at
the beginning of this video cholera
today kills up to 143 000 people every
year but rather than a fact of nature
these deaths are all eminently avoidable
thanks to the pioneering work of people
like jon snow we know what causes
cholera and how it's transmitted we even
know how to treat it using simple oral
rehydration solution in a good world in
a just world cholera would have been
defeated long ago now it would just be
an illness that occasionally struck the
unfortunate after eating contaminated
shellfish say and it would only ever
rarely kill anyone sadly that's not the
world we live in for most of us here
today watching this video cholera is as
old-fashioned as top hats mutton chopped
sideburns and supporting the british
empire it's a thing from history
something to give us a little thrill as
a knowledgeable bald man teaches us
about it for others though it's a real
threat a live problem they have to deal
with every day as deadly now as it was
before jon snow ever thought to examine
that broad street pump the era of great
cholera pandemics that swept the globe
may be mostly over but we shouldn't
forget that the sun the time of cholera
sadly never ended
so i hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit the
thumbs up button below don't forget to
subscribe thank you for watching
[Music]